our brain is made up of billions of
neurons and they are connected by
junctions known as synapses out of these
billions of neurons there are several
categories of neuron which are
excitatory in nature and there are also
neurons which are inhibitory in nature
let's just take a moment to look at what
we mean by excitatory or inhibitory
major of a neuron excitatory neuron
would be those neurons which would be
able to elicit an action potential or a
spike from its postsynaptic target here
in the left hand side of the screen you
can see the blue neuron is able to
squeeze out the action potential from
its postsynaptic target you're on your
own so that means the blue neuron would
secrete some excitatory neurotransmitter
which would elicit action potential from
its postsynaptic target neuron whereas
on the right-hand side of the screen the
you're on your own you see it is failing
to give rise to an action potential from
its postsynaptic target hence it's an
inhibitory neuron inhibitory neuron
would use inhibitory neurotransmitter
and one of the most popular inhibitory
neurotransmitter is known as gamma amino
butyric acid or GABA now gaba would once
released in a synaptic cleft would bind
to either GABA a type receptor or cover
P type receptor gobernador receptors are
ligand gated ion channels whereas cover
P type receptors are metabotropic now
once GABA
bind to the cover a type receptor it
would allow chloride ion to come inside
of the postsynaptic membrane
well on the postsynaptic cell so what
would happen is the postsynaptic cell
would become more hyperpolarized in
simple warned the postsynaptic inside of
the postsynaptic neuron in more negative
charge would build up so the membrane
potential would drop even lower than the
resting membrane potential that means it
is going away and away from the
threshold for firing an action potential
and that's why it failed to fire an
action potential will when gaba is the
inhibitory neurotransmitter now question
is whether gaba is always inhibitory or
not and it turns out that gaba is
inhibitory or not it is determined based
on the chlorides reversal potential when
the chloride reversal potential is would
determine whether gaba would impart an
excitatory or inhibitory effect it is
true that kaabah in several early stage
of development
imparts an excitatory effect now here in
the early phase and rodent data shows
that in early phase of development
rodent brain shows that the chloride
reversal potential is minus 40 milli
volt whereas in the postnatal day in a
third phase the towards reversal
potential is minus eighty millivolts so
there is a drastic difference in the
chloride reversal potential in both the
cases and what the clearance reversal
potential is different and what is the
effect of it so in case of a new natural
condition the cytoplasmic chloride
concentration is pretty high because
there is a KCC to transporter presenting
the neurons are pretty much known in
case of no return' situation or early
phase of the deepwater development case
ec2 is a potassium dependent chloride
transporter so potassium concentration
is more in inside and less in outside so
production would generally try to go out
and using the that gradient chloride
would also go out now here chloride much
of the chloride cannot go out because
the level of KCC 2 is pretty low that
means inside of the neuron inside of the
cytosol a lot of fluorine ion is paid up
now what happens when gaba binds instead
of chloride coming in from outside
chloride is going out so a negative
charge is going out of the neuron that
means the membrane potential is going
towards more depolarizing side and once
it crosses the action potential
threshold
near about - 40 millivolt or so it would
fire an action potential so in early
phase of development gaba could be a
excitatory gamma could have an
excitatory effect but at the later stage
of development in the in the
and don't face what happens the
cytosolic chloride concentration dropped
dramatically because the KCC to
expression
it increases several folds so once there
are a lot of KCC - what happens is a lot
of chloride is pumped outside that means
when once GABA bind to the gaba a Tec
receptor a lot of chloride comes in from
the outside that makes the membrane even
more hyperpolarized and there is no
chance that the postsynaptic neuron
would fire an action potential so that
tells us that chloride reversal
potential determined by the chloride
concentration and luan concentration is
regulated by the cases we to expression
level and then that is why the early
phase of development gaba could have an
excitatory effect whereas in the adult
phase cover doesn't have a excitatory
effect its effect is inhibitory and the
whole reason is its reversal potential
is different and the chloride
concentration is different and always
recruit all of these factors are
regulated by the expression level of KCC
- transporter
so that is why gaba is not only
inhibitory though its main roles are
majorly inhibitory but fit at at the
early stage of development gaba could
also have a excitatory effect I hope you
liked my video if you enjoyed my video
give it a big thumbs up don't let it
show so don't forget to share subscribe
thank you